voilà donc merci à vous madame rousé
Madame et Monsieur donc Madame Trigano
d'avoir répondu présent à notre
invitation à cette audition donc vous
avez devant vous trois rapporteurs de
cette mission d'information sur la crise
du logement donc avec une mission que
nous voulons volontairement contraindre
dans le temps nous espérons rendre le
rapport à la mi-mars pour pour que nous
puissions être force de proposition à
travers à la fois des propositions et
des et des mesures qui puissent être des
mesures conjoncturelles mais aussi des
mesures structurelles et peut-être nous
l'espérons aussi un certain nombre de
mesures pour le moins disruptives ou en
tout cas qui sortent un petit peu des
mesures habituelles qui sont donc
présentées dans le cadre d'une crise qui
je crois pouvoir le dire est extrêmement
grave et préoccupante et donc la
commission des affaires économiques à la
demande du président du Sénat c'est
saisi de ce sujet et donc nous sommes
toutes les trois rapporteurs de cette
mission d'information euh après donc en
fonction du rapport que nous
présenterons en commission on verra
comment nous déclinons euh les
propositions qui seront faites dans ce
rapport soit sous forme d'une PPL soit à
travers des amendements qui pourraient
être portés dans le cadre d'un futur
projet de loi sur le logement je dis
futur parce qu'aujourd'hui on a plus
aucune visibilité sur les textes
législatifs à venir puisque avant à la
fin de l'année le ministre en charge du
logement nous parlerit d'une grande loi
sur le logement pour le mois d'avril
2024 avec un certain nombre de sujets
sur lesquels il renvoyer à chaque fois
cette grande loi bon aujourd'hui on sait
plus plus très bien puisque on est quand
même dans un certain flou en attendant
que nous nous y voyons plus clair avec
nous l'espérons un ministre délégué en
charge du log ement mais on va on va
attendre et pour autant nous continuons
nos travaux donc nous sommes donc toutes
les trois cette mission d'information
nous la voulons transpartisane comme on
a l'habitude souvent de le faire dans le
cadre des travaux que nous portons au
Sénat et au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques donc Amel gaaker
qui est donc séndatrice du ptecalis pour
le groupe Union centriste Vivien
Artigalas qui est la sénatrice des
Hautes Pyrénées pour le groupe
socialiste et moi-même président de la
commission d'affaires économique
c'estatrice maritime pour le groupe les
républicains donc on a l'habitude de
travailler ensemble c'est de des sujets
qui nous passionnent toutes les trois et
sur lesquel bon voilà on espère
véritablement à travers les auditions
que l'on conduit pouvoir trouver un
certain nombre de de de de mesures et en
tout cas disposer à travers les
personnes qui sont auditionnées de
d'éléments et je crois que c'est
important de pouvoir vous auditionner
aujourd'hui donc nous en sommes ravis
nous auditionnons donc après vous nous
aurons
l'OCDE et puis demain nous aurons de
nouveau des des experts dans le domaine
du logement donc on a des auditions qui
ont une tournir en tout cas une
dimension qui est plus économique pour
aller plus en avant dans la
compréhension de la crise et
naturellement les solutions qui
pourraient être mises en œuvre donc je
vous remercie madame rousé qui être chef
économiste de la direction générale du
Trésor et vous êtes accompagné de Madame
Éléonore Trigano qui est sous-directrice
des politiques publiques donc madame
rousé vous avez succédé courant 2003 à
Madame Agnès Benassi keré c'est ça que
nous avons auditionné pas plus tard que
la semaine dernière son intervention
lors de l'ouverture du Conseil national
de la refondation sur le logement en
novembre 2022 avait marqué les esprits
car elle était allée contre l'idée d'un
logement en crise et d'une insuffisance
de la construction aujourd'hui nous
souhaiterions bien sûr à travers
votre parole savoir quelle est la vision
de la direction générale du Trésor et
donc dans une certaine mesure de l'état
du besoin du logement et de la crise du
logement pour vous quelles en sont ces
caractéristiques et ces cause à quelle
crise antérieure peut-on la comparer
est-ce que c'est plutôt la crise que
nous avons connu en 2008 ou celle des
années
1990 peut-on d'ailleurs tirer un certain
nombre de leçon des politiques
économiques suivies puisque la politique
monétaire avec les taux d'intérêt très
bas et l'un des ressorts principaux de
la situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui concernant le besoin en
logement que pensez-vous des chiffres
avancés dans des études récentes qui
finalement valident un objectif national
d'au moins
400000 si on inclut la résorption du mal
logement c'est en tout cas ce qui ress
sort des travaux du Conseil national de
l'habitat le CNH enfin il nous serait
également très utile que vous puissiez
nous indiquer quells sont pour vous les
politiques économiques ou les outils à
mettre en œuvre si ce n'est pour mettre
fin à la crise au moins pour diminuer
les tensions dans le logement et ce
peut-être plus d'un point de vue
structurel que conjoncturel voilà donc
sans plus tarder je vous laisse la
parole pour une vingtaine 30 de minutes
en tout cas c'est vous qui qui le
déciderez bien évidemment pour qu'après
nous puissions de nouveau échanger et
que mes collègues vous posent bien sûr
un certain nombre de questions et je me
permettrai de préciser que notre
audition fait l'objet d'une
retransmission en vidéo en direct et à
la demande sur le site internet bien sûr
sur les réseaux sociaux du Sénat voilà
madame la chef économiste je vous laisse
la parole bien
volontiers merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente et merci pour votre
invitation
à exprimer les les analyses et les vues
de la direction générale du Trésor sur
ce sujet
euh alors j'ai euh un diaporama qui
recourt effectivement pour répondre à
vos questions à la fois sur les aspects
structurels de la crise du marché
immobilier et le diagnostic plus
structurel on peut peut-être commencer
directement par la diapo numéro 4 pour
commencer sur l'aspect sur l'aspect
conjoncturel vous l'avez dit le le
principal facteur c'est bien le
resserrement de la politique monétaire
et c'est qui a
été historique à la fois par sa rapidité
et par son ampleur puisque les taux
directeurs de la Banque centrale
européenne ont augmenté de 450 points de
base depuis la mi- 2022 avec une
transmission som toutes bon assez rapide
enfin dans des délais assez normaux de
transmission de de hausse des taux au
taux long sur les nouveaux crédits
immobiliers qui aboutissent à un taux
moyen qui en 2 ans de fin 2021 à fin
2023 augmenté de presque trois points
euh se traduisant par une perte de
capacité d'emprunt des ménages et c'est
bien ce ressort de la hausse des taux
qui est la la la principale cause du du
marché immobilier grippé que l'on
observe aujourd'hui euh ici vous voyez
sur le graphique la chute de la
production mensuelle de crédit hors
renégociation qui est ce ce qu'on
regarde qui atteint 8,7 milliards
d'euros en novembre alors qu' a une
chute particulièrement euh euh marqué de
plus de moitié par rapport au niveau de
2021 2021 c'était un niveau assez élevé
mais même quand on compare aux années
précovid on a une chute de volume de
l'ordre de de 20 %. cette chute elle
s'explique d'abord par effectivement ce
ces ces conditions de crédit rerré qui
font chuter la demande de crédit de la
part des ménages davantage que par un
changement de de comportement d'octroi
de la part des banques ce qui est
intéressant aussi quand on voit qui elle
touche ça ne change pas tellement la
répartition euh dans les crédits
immobiliers octroyés entre les Primot
accédant et les autres la part de Primot
accédant reste stable à peu près 50 % en
revanche la part de ménage modeste parmi
ces primes acccédents Hut donc c'est
bien eux qui sont les plus les plus
affectés euh ça se retrouve sur la
diapos suivante sur les transactions
immobilières euh donc ce ce diagnostic
est connu aujourd'hui on a une chute des
transactions immobilières qui étaé assez
marquée au 3è trimestre donc qui les
dernières données dont on disp Cuse pour
l'ensemble des transactions on a une
chute de 18 % sur 1 an mais
particulièrement marqué sur le segment
du neu qui est le plus affecté où la
chute est est de fois plus
importante et je pense que c'est
important d'avoir vraiment ce je dirais
cette cette vision du secteur immobilier
qui est qui est multiple le secteur de
la construction neuve Dépau suivante est
bien particulièrement en crise mais ce
n'est pas l'ensemble du du du marché
immobilier ou du secteur de de la
construction j'y reviendrai dans un
instant pour le secteur de la conr
conruction neu on a eu à la fois cette
chute de la demande affecté par les
conditionutions de crédit et en même
temps l'effet donc un effet imp plus
ciseau avec des contraintes d'offre sur
les coûts de contre construction les
difficultés de recrutement qui se sont
additionnés au aux effets de la demande
et on en voit on en voit toujours
l'impact sur une dégradation assez
continue des
indicateurs avancés comme les permis de
construire et les et les mises en
chantier si on les compare à la période
de 2019 on préfère comparer à 2019 parce
que sur la période covid puis euh plan
de relance en fait il y a eu des mesures
spécifiques qui font qu'en 2022 on a eu
un pic mais qui était porté par des
mesures spécifiqu quand on compare à
2019 on a environ 15 % de baisse du
nombre de permis de construire euh donc
avec un un niveau qui
euh qui se voilà se se stabilise en 2023
autour de 370000 autorisations et dans
les logements mis en chantier donc
c'està-dire l'étape suivante aussi une
baisse plus continue et un peu plus
marquée en 2023 euh qui est pour
l'instant inférieure de 27 % à son
niveau de 2019 on voit tout de même dans
les permis de constr dans les permis de
construire une tendance à la
stabilisation sur les derniers points
qui peut augurer d'une stabilisation à
venir des mises en chantier et puis euh
euh des des transactions dans dans le
neuf à venir typiquement il y a un à de
trimestres entre les permis de
construire et les mises en chantier euh
en revanche quand on regarde euh je
dirais d'autres aspects du secteur de la
construction donc sur sur la diapo
suivante euh on a une partie qui va bien
c'est la partie rénovation et notamment
entretien amélioration dont il faut pas
oublier que en terme notamment d'emploi
ou en terme d'activité c'est une part
très importante du du secteur de de la
construction et du bâtiment pris dans
son ensemble et qui est porté notamment
par la rénovation énergétique les aides
publiques à la rénovation donc dans ce
secteur les les enquêtes de conjoncture
montrent que l'activité a-udessus de sa
moyen de long terme que les perspectives
sont positives diagnostic qui est
d'ailleurs partagé par par la FFB sur
sur ce segment euh donc une activité qui
est assez dégradée et dans le dans le
neuf où se concentrre vraiment les
difficultés mais par ailleurs qui
continue à se porter bien dans
l'entretien amélioration euh sur la
diapo suivante donc ensuite on on si on
compare euh euh donc à la fois dans le
dans le temps et en terme géographique
où se situe la France par rapport aux
autres pays européens pour lesquels on
dispose de de données on a pas de
données sur les transactions pour tous
les pays européens mais dans
leschantillons dont on dispose B VO la
France dans une position assez médiane
avec une baisse donc la France est en
rouge une baisse des transactions
immobilières de 20 30 % qui est dans la
moyenne alors la hausse des prix a été
aussi assez médiane sur les années qui
ont précédé dans les pays dans certains
pays nordiques on a on a une baisse
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus prononcée
mais globalement la France ne fait pas
ne fait pas figure d'exception en Europe
sur l'ampleur de de de la dégradation et
si on compare dans le temps sur la diapo
suivante notamment par rapport à la
crise de
2008-2009 on est aussi dans des ordres
de grandeur assez similaires
c'est-à-dire qu'en 2008-29 on avait eu
une baisse de transaction de 24 % là on
en est à 18 % cumulés sur un an si on
prend l'ensemble de l'année 2023 ça
pourrait être un peu plus prononcé donc
atteindre là aussi les mêmes ordres de
grandeur et c'est la crise qui qui
semble la plus comparable donc vous avez
parlé des années 90 dans les années 90
ça a été un peu plus diffus un peu plus
étalé dans le temps que en 2009 ou ou
aujourd'hui
euh alors pourquoi cette chute massive
des des des transactions euh sur la
diapo suivante s'il vous plaît euh c'est
tout simplement parce que ce qui est
assez typique en fait dans un contexte
de de hausse des taux euh l'ajustement
par les prix prend du temps les prix
sont assez rigides à la baisse et du
coup entre temp on a un comportement
euh un peu attentiste à la fois des
vendeurs et des acheteurs qui gèlent le
marché et qui donc fait chuter fait
chuter les transactions sur les prix
immobiliers on a eu un petit peu de
baisse mais seulement de de 2 % en
termes nominaux depuis le pic
euh si on prend en compte le fait que
pendant ce temps-là les autres prix
augmentaient et donc on prend le une
baisse en termes réels on est plutôt à 4
% mais ça reste là inférieur à ce qu'on
a observé entre 2 8 et 2009 donc on peut
s'attendre à ce que la baisse des prix
se poursuive mais elle prend du temps
elle prend pas non plus du temps de
manière particulièrement atypique dans
dans la zone dans la zone euro mais dans
certains pays et on pourra le voir sur
sur la slide suivante également comme
Allemagne Autriche Pays-Bas on a une
baisse plus marquée mais aussi après une
hausse qui avait été plus marqué dans
les années précédentes donc des prix
immobiliers qui avaient été plus
dynamiques dans la période précovid et
qui ont davantage corrigé à la baisse
depuis l'épisode de la hausse des
taux donc voilà c'est à la fois un
décalage dans le temps entre la
transmission de la hausse des taux et le
moment où les prix se sont suffisamment
ajustés pour restaurer la capacité
d'achat des
ménages qui qui qui crée ce ce ce ce gel
enfin ce cette ouais ce ce ce gel des
transactions en insens dans l'attente
alors ça a des effets sur sur la diapo
suivante ça a des effets qui se
répercute sur le parc
locatif alors là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile d'avoir d'avoir des données on
n' pas de données officielles vraiment
sur le parc locatif donc ici on
montre donc un graphique sur les
annonces sur le site sur un site
d'annonce immobiliare mais de sources
meilleurs agents on n pas de donné
vraiment de de statistique publique sur
sur ce planl mais l'offre locative
semble bien diminuer assez nettement
depuis le début de l'année derni de
l'année
2022 donc avec ave sans doute un effet
euh indirect de ce qui se passe sur le
sur le marché enfin sur l'accession à la
propriété puisque les personnes qui
seraient sorties du parc locatif pour
devenir
primoaccédent le font moins et
potentiellement aussi des effets sur les
passeirs thermiques qui seraient plutôt
temporaires liés aux obligations de
rénovation potentiellement également en
effet du du plionnement de la hausse des
loyers mais encore une fois on a assez
peu de donné pour vraiment quantifier
ces facteurs ou ou faire un diagnostic
plus plus précis
euh si on se focalise alors là en
passant un peu entre le conjoncturel et
le structurel sur justement cette
question des obligations de de
rénovation dép suivante
[Musique]
euh il il s'agit donc
pour le parc locatif de 42 % du parc
privé qui va potentiellement être
concerné par une obligation de roviation
alors qui s'étal entre eux pour les les
logements les plus énergivores janvier
2023 et davantage en terme quantitatif
sur 2025 2028 2034
euh bon avec un certain nombre de de
conditions et d'exemption euh l'effet
vraiment sur le parc leatif est là aussi
assez assez difficile à apprécier parce
qu'on a peu de précédents historiques
euh on a des obligations similaires qui
ont été mises en place en Angleterre et
au Pays de Gall euh plutôt en 2018 alors
qui sont pas exactement identiques mais
qui ressemblent euh dont les effets pour
l'instant n'ont pas vraiment été de
retirer des logements du parc locatif en
revanche il est difficile d'apprécier si
la les rénovations ont vraiment eu lieu
euh ce qu'on semble voir c'est un impact
sur la valeur des des logements les plus
énergivores donc des passeirs thermiques
qui en soi devrait constituer aussi une
incitation à la rénovation puisque si je
rénove mon bien il va gagner en valeur
euh donc ça incite également les
propriétaires à la rénovation mais on ne
semble pas avoir en tout cas observé sur
ces exemples certes limités de de
sorties massif du parc locatif et
l'autre aspect qui est davantage
structurel mais mais persistant c'est
euh sur la question du logement social
euh on n'a pas euh retrouvé le niveau de
production de logements sociaux euh euh
précovid et ça ne semble pas vraiment
être lié euh à des à des difficultés
financières puisque globalement les
bailleurs sociaux ont une santé
financière assez solide ils ont aussi
été soutenus par des mesures qui qui ont
permis de de faire face aux crises avec
leur intégration dans le Bouclier
tarifaire sur le gaz avec le gel du du
taux du Livret à 3 % pour pour contenir
la hausse de leur coût de financement
également des des subventions publiques
de 1,2 milliard d'euros pour la
rénovation du parc social et donc quand
on regarde le le le leur santé
financière elle ne semble pas
particulièrement dégradé en revanche il
il y a d'autres raisons plus
structurelles y compris la dépendance au
promoteur immobilier qui peut aussi
expliquer ses difficulté à faire
remonter le le niveau de production de
de logements
sociaux donc peut-être pour conclure sur
cette partie diagnostique euh du moment
euh donc je dirais encore une fois le
facteur principal c'est c'est d'abord la
hausse des taux et ce décalage avec
entre l'ajustement par les quantités et
l'ajustement par les prix un diagnostic
un peu différent selon le secteur de la
construction neuve qui qui est au cœur
de de ceux qui qui souffrent et euh et
d'autres parties comme la rénovation qui
se porte plutôt bien mais avec des des
effets aussi sur le parc locatif et des
effets de bord sur la
mobilité ensuite quand on regarde les
choses de manière plus structurelle et
ça sera mon mon deuxième grand point
euh le je dirais le le diagnostic
d'ensemble c'est quand même d'un soutien
public structurel assez important à
porter au secteur du logement on se
focalise souvent sur les les aspects
fiscaux mais le soutien public est est
plus large peut-être un premier point
quand on regarde d'abord la taxation du
secteur
euh
et on peut entendre que le secteur du
logement est particulièrement taxé alors
quand on regarde en comparaison
internationale la fiscalité sur le
logement en pourcentage du PIB elle va
sans doute ressortir assez élevé mais en
fait c'est le cas de beaucoup
d'assiettes puisque tout simplement la
France a un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire assez important en
comparaison internationale et ça se
reflète sur toutes les assiettes en
revanche si on regarde quelle est la de
la fiscalité du logement dans l'ensemble
des prélèvements obligatoires on est
dans une position un peu plus
intermédiaire où il y a un poids un peu
plus important que dans un certain
nombre de pays d'Europe continentale
mais moindre que dans les pays
anglo-saxons par exemple donc ce niveau
voilà ce niveau d'ensemble de fiscalité
du logement en tout cas ne fait pas de
la France une exception et par ailleurs
en face de cette fiscalité on a des
déenses en faveur du secteur qui sont
assez importantes en comparaison
internationale euh puisque les dépenses
publiques en faveur du
logement dans dans les données qui sont
harmonisées au niveau européen montrre
que la France dépense 1,9 % de ces
dépenses publiques pour le logement ce
qui est un un taux assez nettement
supérieur à celui de nos voisins et qui
sont en partie des dépenses fiscales
mais également les prestations sociales
don les aides au logement et donc
certains avantages fiscaux à la fois
côté production et côté euh travaux
rénovation par exemple euh donc dans
dans l'ensemble de ces dépenses
publiques les réformes récentes ont
plutôt visé à la fois renforcer
l'efficience de ces dépenses pour
vraiment avoir un effet déclencheur sur
la construction de logement là où elle
est nécessaire et également de basculer
le soutien vers plus de soutien à la
rénovation sur ce premier sur le premier
point de recherche d'efficacité on a le
recentrage du préo zéro et la
suppression du Pinel qui est prévu au
1er janvier 2025 qui en fait répondent à
des évaluations qui ont été faites par
euh un certain nombre d'institutions qui
qui montraient de manière assez claire
les effets d'obaines de ces de de ces
dispositifs et des effets inefficaces
alors sur le PTZ en particulier sur le
fait l'effet plutôt
artificialisant en zone détendue euh sur
le Pinel l'effet inflationniste sur les
prix de l'immobilier qui du coup allit
un peu à l'encontre de l'objectif
recherché d'accessibilité euh donc qui
qui ont qui ont guidé euh les euh
recentrages de de ces dispositifs et la
suppression prévue du Pinel en face de
ça le soutien public à la rénovation sur
la diapo suivante est monté en puissance
pour à la fois favoriser une
meilleure efficacité énergétique et
également une une meilleure occupation
du du parc existant euh donc avec
notamment la réforme de maprbrenov à
partir du 1er janvier qui vise à à la
fois avoir un effet plus important sur
les économies d'énergie en favorisant
les rénovations d'ampleur et et les le
remplacement des des systèmes de
chauffage qui qui consomment le plus
d'énergie et en même temps une
augmentation de l'enveloppe consacrée au
dispositif de 1,6 milliard d'euros
euh en face de ça dans l'ensemble des
politiques publiques je vais peut-être
pas revenir sur les questions de normes
d'roit créal puisque vous avez
auditionné le le
hcsf simplement pour dire que de notre
point de vue effectivement le le le cœur
de du sujet se trouve davantage du côté
de la demande de crédit plus que du côté
de de de difficultés enfin du du côté de
l'optroit de crédit euh les ajustements
qui ont été décidés par le hcsf sont
assez bienvenus pour permettre justement
de de de faire face au au au au grain de
sable qui qui se'ppos aux banques de
manière opérationnelle quand elles
veulent utiliser leur marge de
flexibilité mais il nous semble que que
les politiques sur ce point sont assez
équilibrées
euh donc voilà pour pour conclure sur
cet aspect des des réformes récentes et
du soutien structurel au logement qui
prend la forme de de à la fois de
dispositifs mais dans laquelle on
recherche l'efficacité et de soutien à
la rénovation un dernier point peut-être
très rapidement sur la
question de l'occupation du parc
existant qui nous semble aussi assez
centrale dans un contexte où à la
fois on a des besoins de logement
importants on a des
contraintes sur l'artificialisation des
sols euh et donc pour revenir à votre
question à la question que vous avez
posé sur comment on appréhende le
besoins en logement effectivement il
nous semble que sur ce concept de
besoins en logement quand on articule
des chiffres j' dirais agrégés au niveau
national il faut mettre un peu deux deux
nuances autour de ce concept
euh bon une nuance qui qui
est qui qui ressort de manière générale
qui est le besoin de territorialiser
c'està-dire que un besoin logement
agrégé ça veut pas dire grand-chose il
faut construire là où les gens ont envie
d'habiter euh et et on on a plutôt des
des construction
euh qui vont un peu trop vers les zones
détendues et pas assez vers les zones
tendues donc quand on n' pas cette
approche territorialisée finalement a
besoin de logement agrégé ne veut pas
forcément dire grand-chose en terme de
d'accès au logement des Français et
également de regarder dans ces chiffres
exactement de quoi on parle euh parce
que le besoin la construction neuve euh
en moyenne est plutôt euh excédentaire
par rapport aux besoins en résidence
principal quand on inclut les besoins je
dirais dictés par des causes
structurelles de d'évolution
démographique de décohabitation qui
augmente et de de renouvellement normal
et plus la résorption du malogement en
revanche dans les chiffres qu'on voit
circuler on voit aussi euh ce qui
correspond à des logements vacants ou à
des besoins nouveaux en résidence
secondaire il nous semble qu'il faut
d'abord se focaliser sur les besoins en
résidence principal pour à la fois enfin
répondre à la demande un peu elle et et
résorber le mal logement et selon ces
critères alors les estimations varient
mais de manière générale le voilà les
chiffres agrégés de construction neuve
sont plutôt supérieurs sur les années
récentes à ce qui serait nécessaire
évidemment ça veut pas dire que ces
nouveaux logements sont situés au bon
endroit par rapport à à la demande de
logement mais c'est un premier élément
de de
diagnostic et donc ensuite quand on
quand on essaie de justement
territorialiser ce ce regard sur
suivante s'il vous plaît euh donc on a
fait cet exercice de regarder au fond où
construit-on et où sont les logements
vacants et quand on regarde au niveau de
de la commune donc commune par commune
on voit que coexiste au sein des mêmes
communes des logements qui deviennent
vacants et des constructions neuves qui
correspondent à à peu près 10 % en flux
des nouveaux logements donc on a fait
cette analyse sur 2019 et sur 2019 on a
34000 logements qui ont été autorisés
alors que dans la la même année au moins
autant de logement même vous voyez sur
le graphique plutôt plus puisque c'était
49000 logements devenaient vacant dans
la même commune où c'est ces nouvelles
constructions ont eu lieu donc c'est ce
qu'on décrirait de manière un peu
générale comme des constructions
potentiellement et potentiellement
évitable puisqu'elles ont lieu en même
temps que des logements deviennent
vacants à côté qui auraiit peut-être pu
être rénovés pour être occupés et sur le
stock alors évidemment le stock ne
s'appliquerait pas chaque année mais en
2019 on avait 250000 logements qui ont
été autorisés alors que au moins autant
de logements étaient vacants depuis au
moins 2 ans dans la même commune
euh si on regarde où sont ces flux enfin
où sont ces où c'est cette coexistence
de de construction évitable euh et de
enfin de de de construction et de
logement vacant donc ce qu'on appelle
les constructions évitables elles sont
en grande majorité en zone détendue
c'est enfin c'est vraiment là que on
peut réfléchir à comment mieux mobiliser
le parc existant et notamment les
logements les logements vacant alors que
en zone tendue le c'est c'est un peu
moins un sujet en zone tendue ce qu'on
ce qu'on observe davantage mais qui qui
pose d'autres questions moins évidentes
c'est une coexistence de nouvelles
constructions et de logements qui
deviennent des résidences secondaires
dans la même commune dans la même année
c'est-à-dire qu'on construit soit pour
construire des résidences secondaires
soit on construit à côté de de logement
qui deviennent des résidences
secondaires plutôt que des résidences
principales donc voilà c'était pour pour
conclure cette présentation ça pose voil
ça pose un peu des questions
d'optimisation du parc qui comme je le
disais sont d'autant plus importantes
que euh en même temps les objectifs de
zéro artificialisation nette sont sont
assez ambitieux et demandent à optimiser
cette gestion du du parc existant de
logement à mieux mobiliser la rénovation
pour pour utiliser les logements qui
existent déjà euh je terminerai
là-dessus en espérant ne pas avoir été
été trop longue donc je dirais de
manière générale hein sur le diagnostic
conjoncturel c'est vrai vraiment un
diagnostic de
euh d'un marché du logement qui est
grippé d'abord par le par la
construction neuve en raison
principalement de la hausse des taux qui
demande de s'adapter pour répondre au
besoins logement mais dans une approche
assez fine des besoins au logement et
pour le secteur dans son ensemble avec
probablement un secteur qui doit évoluer
aussi vers plus de rénovation
euh dans au cœur de son activité euh et
donc ça c'est c'est aussi là que
l'adaptation des outils de politique
économique va aussi vers davantage de
soutien à la rénovation et davantage
d'efficacité dans le soutien à la
construction de neuv qui se focalise
d'abord sur le le les zones tendues
d'abord sur l'habitat collective où les
où les besoins restent important
merci merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation je vais laisser la parole
sans plus tarder à mes collègu on entend
enfin de plus en plus en tout cas on
entend un certain discours sur le fait
qu'il faudrait arrêter de faire une
distinction entre les zones tendues et
les zones détendues euh vous quellez
votre position
là-dessus merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente eu alors sur cette question
j'imagine que on fait référence plutôt à
la mise à jour nécessaire des zones
tendues et des zones détendues puisqu'il
y a un enjeu on le sait tous à faire
partie des zones tendues et donc une
demande forte vous le savez probablement
mieux que moi des territoires de faire
partie de ces zones tendues en revanche
il nous semble que la dichotomie reste
intéressante au niveau macro ne
serait-ce que parce que comme le montit
madame rousé à l'instant vous avez une
répartition des logements vacants par
exemple qui diffèrent beaucoup entre
zone tendue et zone tendue nous au
trésor on porte la recommandation de
mobiliser au mieux le parc existant et
notamment les logements vacants en
revanche on se rend compte avec ce type
de diichotomie que les logements vacants
ils sont beaucoup en zone des détendu
les résidences secondaires c'est une
autre question elles souvent vont se
retrouver en concurrence avec des
résidences principales dans les zones
tendues et en particulier dans les zones
côtières bien
sûr mais mais là aussi sur la vacance
des logements certes il est vrai que on
peut constater qu'il y a plus de
logements vacants peut-être dans les
zones détendues mais on on se pose aussi
la question sur ces logements on voit
bien que pour certains d'entre eux ils
ne correspondent plus euh aux attentes
et aux besoins de nos concitoyens de
famillees enfin quand on parle de de
logements qui sont situés dans des dans
des centrebourg dans et qui sont pas
adaptés à la vie aujourd'hui donc oui on
dit on tapablee sur les logements
vacants mais c'est pas forcément parce
que ces logements sont vacants que
demain il pourrait répondre à une à une
véritable demande dans dans ces zones
détendues porté par des gens qui
habitent déjà ou en tout cas des
personnes qui seraient susceptibles de
de venir s'installer donc c'est aussi
toute la question sur la la vacance des
logements
euh on voit étude après étude ou des
articles qui disent regardez le nombre
de logements vacants il suffirait de les
remettre sur le marché tout parti pour
quelque part solutionner la crise du
logement sauf que c'est pas aussi simple
que ça sur ce qu'on entend dans les
logements vacants et véritablement où
est-ce qu'ils se trouvent quels sont ces
logements vacants est-ce que demain
s'ils étaient remis sur le marché
peut-être qu'ils ne trouveraient pas
plus preneur parce que voilà ils sont
plus du tout adaptés à ce que les les
gens aspirent à pouvoir occuper au
regard de voilà de la modernité de la
vie donc c'est c'est souvent un peu
trompeur que de de de de de parler que
de logement
vacant non je pense que le le le
discours n'est pas de dire il suffirait
de les remettre sur le marché si c'était
oui si c'était si c'était aussi simple
effectivement on leurit sans doute déjà
fait euh mais je pense qu'il y a une
réflexion à avoir sur justement comment
adapter ces logements vacants qui vont
souvent demander des travaux euh quand
je parlais de rénovation c'est pas
uniquement rénovation énergétique mais
typiquement ça peut être des logements
qui n'ont pas sur lesquels il n'y a pas
eu de travaux depuis un certain temps
sils sont vit depuis 2 ans c'est mais
euh de de réfléchir aussi à
euh la rentabilité relative entre euh
rénover un logement vacant pour qu'il
devienne adapté aux demandes euh des euh
des personnes qui voudrait soit
s'installer soit déménager et cetera et
construire un logement neuf pas très
loin quand on regarde au niveau de la
commune c'est que c'est pas des
localisation forcément fondamentalement
différentes euh pour beaucoup de
communes mais effectivement les
caractéristiques des logements peuvent
faire que dans le voilà dans dans dans
les questions de solvabilisation et
cetera il faut il faut se pencher sur
quels travaux sont nécessaires et
comment les rendre comment rendre
rentable le fait de mettre un logement
vacant au normes plutôt que de d'
artificialisé à côté
oui donc moi j'avais quelques questions
mais je voudrais un petit peu revenir
quand même sur dire que de nombrebreuses
voies s'élèv pour des acteurs du
logement mais pas que acteurs du
logement pour parler d'une crise
structurel multifactoriel et et aigu et
qui ne date pas de maintenant qui date
de il y a bien longtemps et on alerte
depuis un moment sur cette crise et qui
demande de faire du logement une une
grande cause nationale même l'ancien
ministre Oliv vicllein avait parlé de
d'une bombe sociale et je pense pas que
que ça soit les les quelques mesures qui
ont été prises là qui peuvent arranger
les choses à mon avis moi je voudrais
donc situer au-delà vous nous avez parlé
de maintenant des taux de de ce qui
arrive là qui a sans doute aggravé cette
prise mais vous où est-ce que vous
situez l'origine de cette crise euh et
dans quelle mesure les les les crises
vous l'avez en avvez un petit peu dit
mais je crois que dans quelle mesure
elles l'ont aggravé plutôt que les les
en augmentant le coût de la construction
l'augmentanté d'eau elles l'ont aggravé
mais l'origine elle était là bien avant
d'où où suuez-vous cette origine ensuite
moi je voulais vous parler du logement
social aussi un petit peu vous bon il
vous vous avez l'air de dire que le que
c'est le les acteurs du logement social
qui construisent pas et que ils ont tous
les moyens pour construire puisqu'on les
a beaucoup aidé je pense pas tout à fait
la même chose en tout cas le Conseil là
que 2,42 millions fin 2022 sont de
personnes sont de ménages sont en
attente d'un logement social moi comment
peut-on agir sur ces secteurs puisque
vous avez l'air de dire que que bah le
comment peut-on aider le logement social
les acteurs du logement social à àroître
l'offre pour mieux adapter effectivement
l'offre à la demande et puis bon vous
avez effectivement euh euh parler de de
la suppression de enfin du resserrement
du PTZ et puis de le euh du de la
suppression du du Pinel euh moi je
qu'est-ce que vous pensez mettre en
œuvre qu'il faudrait mettre en œuvre
pour les des aides à l'investissement
locatif euh est-ce que réellement euh
ces euh tous ces dispositifs n'ont eu
aucun effet sur la construction du
logement même à notre mare est-ce que
c'est euh est-ce qu' est-ce que c'est
pas un problème particulier et puis euh
sur la question aussi du euh quelle
quell mesures fiscales ou autrre il
faudrait mettre en place pour réguler le
le foncier euh pour arriver aussi à à à
rendre moins cher le le foncier et pour
le réguler et pour aider aussi alors moi
je voudrais quand même revenir aussi sur
les logements vacans
euh effectivement moi je vient d'un
endroit où j'ai l'impression qu'il n'y a
plus de zone détendue je département des
hautees Pyrénées la zone de montagne là
les prix explosent à tout nouveau tout
se vend à des prix pas possibles les
jeunes peuvent plus se loger peuvent
plus donc il ils s'en vont vers le vers
le Piémont vers un peu plus bas et donc
du coup là aussi les coûts augmentent il
y a des maisons qui sont à vendre mais
c'est des maisons euh vacantes parce
qu'elles soitent des familles des des
successions qui ne souhaitent pas vendre
où on retrouve plus les héritiers mais
les rénovations et les rachats coûte
très cher parce que depuis la crise
aussi les gens veulent revenir vers le
la ruralité et donc ce sont souvent des
euh des soit des étrangers des Belges
des Anglais des qui achètent et qui
rénov à des prix pas possibles donc ces
logements vacans ils sont pas
disponibles pour pour les jeunes et puis
avec le le zéro artificialisation net
ils ne peuvent plus construire ils ont
du mal à se loger donc moi cette notion
de logement vacant la prendre dans son
ensemble je crois c'est pas très bon non
plus pour comme comme analyse je crois
qu'il faut vraiment mieux différencier
un petit peu les choses en fonction des
et vraiment moi je vous le dis dans mon
département où il y a on a on a on a
réussi à avoir quelques communes quand
même de montagnes dans les zones tendues
euh dans en zone dans le décret zone
tendue mais pas autant qu'il aurait
fallu et surtout je redis dans y compris
dans les zones dites détendu il y a
d'énormes problèmes pour loger les les
les les jeunes qui travaillent beaucoup
on a de l'emploi et du coup ils sont
obligés de se loger très loin de
l'endroit où il où il
travaille euh merci peut-être pour euh
alors je essayé de de de répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions
euh sur l'origine de de la crise euh
oui il y a toujours eu du mogement
maintenant on voit que la l'aggravation
de la crise est très nette avec le
resserrement monétaire et que auparavant
dans la période près-29 on avait à la
fois
euh une une une production de de
logement qui était assez dynamique un
nombre de transactions qui étaiit en en
hausse croissante euh comme je le disais
on a moins de données sur la rotation du
parc locatif donc c'est plus difficile à
apprécier euh mais on en tout cas on on
voit clairement une aggravation dans les
dans les questions plus plus
structurelles de des des freins à la
construction
euh on identifie plutôt des questions de
foncier de disponibilité du foncier euh
des questions euh qui peuvent être liées
aussi sur les transactions
au fait que la fiscalité sur les
transactions est assez importante au
fait que les les frais sont assez
importants y compris par exemple les
frais d'entremise immobilière il y a eu
une enquête par exemple de de l'Autorité
de la concurrence sur sur
l'intermédiation immobilière qui montre
que les frais sont plutôt plus
importants donc il y a des des des
freins que qui sont qui sont
préexistants qui ne sont pas forcément
euh lié selon les études et les
évaluations dont on dispose à la
question du rendement de
l'investissement locatif effectivement
sur euh bon sur le pré àau zéro le
recentrage et a été aussi appuyer sur
vraiment ces évaluations d'efficacité
euh pour le rencentrer notamment autour
du du neuf collectif qui est euh là où
les besoins sont sont les plus
importants mais en même temps les
plafonds de revenus des ménages
éligibles ont aussi été rehaussés pour
permettre à davantage de ménages d'avoir
d'y avoir accès euh donc on on n'est pas
dans une dans une suppression complète
loin là euh sur sur le Pinel il y a eu
aussi un certain nombre d'évaluations
qui montrai que l'effet s'est d'abord
retrouvé dans les prix euh plus que dans
des constructions additionnelles
c'est-à-dire que en fait le l'aide
fiscale a été d'abord capté par les pris
qui n'est pas vraiment l'effet
rechercher en terme de
d'accessibilité
euh en terme en terme d'accessibilité
donc c'est aussi voilà cette ça qui qui
a dicté qui a dicté le le fait de de
recentrer ces dispositifs fisc
et de manière générale je dirais dans la
situation actuelle en fait remettre des
dispositifs fiscaux
euh soit de
solvabilisation enfin de d'A
d'aide à à l'investissement locatif
notamment mais enfin du côté
euh je dirais pour pour enrayer la
baisse des prix ne semble pas être
forcément souhaitable puisque en fait ce
dont on a vraiment besoin pour
solvabiliser la demande c'est que les
prix s'ajuste aux nouvelles conditions y
compris aux nouvelles conditions de
financement qui même
si la baisse de l'inflation devrait
permettre une certaine détente des taux
de la BCE ne reviendront pas au niveau
très bas qu'on a qu'on a connu
auparavant donc on a besoin que cet
ajustement se fasse et de ne pas mettre
des politiques publi en travers de C de
cet
ajustement sur le logement social là
aussi enfin il y a un problème
structurel je pense
c'est voulais pas dire les promoteurs
refusent de construire les les baurs
refuse de construire bien au contraire
il y a une imbrication quand même ils
sont quand même dépendants aussi enfin
il y a des des des promoteurs
immobiliers qui eux-mêmes sont en
difficulté donc il y a il y a aussi un
effet de bord sans doute là-dessus euh
de manière plus structurelle sur le
logement social on a aussi un peu un
défaut de rotation du parc euh
c'est-à-dire que les
les les personnes qui notamment excèdent
les plafonds pendant un certain nombre
d'années donc payer un supplément de
loyer mais ne sortent pas forcément du
parc social ce qui ne libère pas des
places et le le demandeur moyen dans le
parc social est bien plus modeste que
l'occupant moyen du parc social donc on
a aussi cette question de comment avoir
plus de rotation du parc qui peut passer
par aussi donc des des mesures sur le
logement locatif intermédiaire qui
permet des sorties justement plus en
douceur là aussi où des mesures ont été
euh ont été annoncées avec l'extension
du nombre de de communes qui sont
éligibles au au régime de du logement
locatif intermédiaire avec euh un un
réengagement aussi de la case des dépôts
et de l'État pour euh pour pour
développer ce ce segment et cetera euh
donc sur le logement social je P on a à
la fois euh bon des questions qui sont
plus enfin qui sont communes dans
l'ensemble sur le foncier sur où
construire et cetera et sur les
incitations d'ensemble des euh à
octroyer des permis de construire pour
pour davantage de logements en zone
entendu et puis cette question de de
rotation qui qui qui mérite
aussi d'être examinée euh sur les
mesures fiscales donc je vousi un peu
répondu sur la question un peu des des
des des incitations fiscales pour le
pour le locatif notamment euh et ensuite
les mesuresfin les les les outils
fiscaux dont on dispose pour revenir
aussi sur sur les logements vacants ou
sur les résidences secondaires sont
davantage euh la taxe sur les logements
vacants le la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires et c'est plus ces
levierers là qui existe ensuite il faut
faudrait examiner un peu
le l'opportunité de de s'en servir pour
pour décourager notamment la
vacance vous voulez compléter avec
plaisir peut-être dire un mot oui sur
l'origine de la crise vous l'avez bien
dit et on le pense aussi effec ement
c'est il y a des tensions structurelles
sur le marché du logement c'est un
marché qui fonctionne mal du point de
vue économique parce que vous avez un
déséquilibre entre l'offre et la demande
qui
date alors ensuite qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour essayer de de résorber ce
déséquilibre et donc de faire qu'il y
ait plus d'offres de logement on a
évoqué la mobilisation du parc existant
et notamment des logements vacants avec
toutes les précautions qui s'imposent on
partage tout à fait les points que vous
avez cité il y a aussi le rééquilibrage
de la fiscalité locative avec notamment
la proposition de loi lemur sur le sujet
et les débats qui ont eu lieu lors du
projet de loi de finance sur la niche
fiscale
rbnb et puis vous avez on on en a parlé
un petit peu sur les passoirs thermiques
un outil qui est le DPE qui a certains
biais méthodologiques notamment un biais
vis-à-vis des petites surfaces et un
biais vis-à-vis du chauffage électrique
qui pourrait être opportunément corrigé
et euh dans cet esprit toujours de
mobiliser au mieux le parc existant et
l'offre de logement aussi bien sur le
marché de la location que sur le marché
de l'achat favoriser les rénovations
c'est ce que le gouvernement fait et
bien sûr former les artisans compétents
sur ces rénovations donc ça c'est le
premier déséquilibre entre offre et
demande et comment on peut essayer de le
résorber au mieux et effectivement il
est structurel mais il est encore plus
amplifié par cette hausse des taux
ensuite on a un marché qui est rigide
c'est-à-dire que il y a peu de
transactions sur ce
marché parce que les frais de notaire
sont historiquement et en comparaison
aux autres pays européens élevés en
France et donc en raison de ces on
appelle ça donc les DMTO vous avez moins
de transaction potentiellement
d'ailleurs l'OCDE nous recommande
régulièrement de les baisser en plus
c'est c'est un outil qui est assez
volatile donc ça vient financer derrière
les les finances locales mais c'est très
volatile et on va avoir des soucis dans
les années à venir sur ce sujet et puis
vous avez un moins bon apparement sur le
marché de l'emploi parce que quand
quelqu'un a un appartement et qu' besoin
de le vendre bah il va y réfléchir à
deux fois parce que ça lui coûte
beaucoup et donc ça ça fait aussi y a
des impacts importants sur le marché de
l'emploi alors maintenant vous dire
aussi que sur le logement il y a des
enjeux un peu contradictoires on a des
enjeux de décarbonation qui a été évoqué
par Madame rousé
euh et puis il on a des enjeux aussi de
pouvoir d'achat et de de volonté
d'accession à la propriété et donc c'est
pas facile d'avoir les bons outils qui
vont venir soutenir ces objectifs qui
sont parfois contre contradictoire
peut-être dire un mot de
l'investissement locatif que vous
évoquiez je pense que le rapport du CPO
a bien documenté ces questions sur le
Pinel il y est écrit que 80 % des
ménages qui en bénéficie font partie du
dernier décil de revenus sur le PTZ et
en cela il est venu confirmer le rapport
IGF CGEDD de 2019 l'effet déclencheur
est moindre et il y a un effet
inflationniste cela ne nous a pas ch de
conserver ce dispositif et de le
prolonger jusqu'en 2027 tout en le
recentrant et aussi en l'ouvrant un peu
plus justement pour viser au mieux les
médage
modeste
Amel merci merci madame la Présidente
alors je vais revenir sur sur
certainement pas en tout cas merci
beaucoup pour pour tous ces éléments sur
les points communs vous avez évoqué de
nombreux points communs entre la crise
de 2008- 200009 et la crise que nous
sommes en train de de traverser euh j'ai
entendu finalement peu de points de
divergence en entre ces deux crises dans
dans votre présentation est-ce que vous
pourriez nous nous dire un peu comment
vous distinguez ces ces deux ces deux
crises
qui non quand même pas tout à fait ni la
même origine ni complètement les mêmes
conséquences je reviens évidemment parce
que c'est quelque chose je pense qui
nous a interpellé hein sur sur la
vacance des logements puisque vous dites
clairement que vous avez donné des
exemples très concrets hein de communes
dans lesquels puisque vous avez une
approche quand même territoriale de ce
que j'ai compris dans lesquels lorsqu'on
regarde l'état de construction de
nouveaux logement et de vacances on peut
se poser la question de savoir s'il y
avait vraiment intérêt puisque c'est ça
de façon assez simpliste à à construire
moi en fait ma question plutôt ma ma
remarque c'est c'est de savoir quelle
approche vous avez eu vous avez une
approche bien sûr
quantitative bien sûr quantitative
est-ce que il y a eu une approche
qualitative et c'est extrêmement
important pour nous pour vous pour nous
qui vivons dans les territoires cette
importance
elle c'est ce qui fait que parfois on
peut avoir le sentiment d'avoir des
points de divergence dans nos analyses
c'est que en fonction des territoire je
le redis ce que nous vivons est très
différent et c'est un point essentiel
dans ce que nous vivons nous subissons
dans cette crise du logement que nous
traversons vous je vais revenir parce
que c'est vraiment des discussions que
nous avons beaucoup hein sur cette fin
du Pinel recentrage du PTZ j'ai entendu
hein vos vos arguments très clair à
Madame Trigano hein sur sur les éléments
qui confortent finalement les choix qui
ont été faits de mettre un terme ou en
tout cas de recentrer ces politiques ma
question est très simple au regard de la
crise que nous vivons euh à l'écoute de
tous les acteurs tous les acteurs du
logement aujourd'hui n'auraiit-il pas
été intéressant ou est-ce que nous
n'aurions pas pu différer euh en tout
cas ces ces ces annonces dans le temps
pour peut-être amortir cette crise en
tout cas cette crise pardon les effets
de ces décisions excusez-moi euh
pourquoi parce que vous savez l'impact
économique euh de ces de de la crise que
nous vivons aujourd'hui est est terrible
pour nos acteurs et lorsque nous aurons
besoin de reprise euh on se posera la
question de savoir où sont nos
entreprises quel compétences aurons-nous
encore aujourd'hui des compétences
disponibles pour pouvoir en tout cas
accompagner accompagner la
reprise je reviens aussi sur la
réglementation qui vise à lutter contre
les passoirs
énergétiques vous avez été très
transparent en
expliquant en évoquant le manque de
précédent en fait sur l'impact de cette
réglementation vous avez évoquer
également deux exemples l'Angleterre les
pays de Gal et puis un chiffre qui est
quand même marquant he c'est les 42 %
aujourd'hui de de logement qui
correspondent à ce à ces passoirs
énergétiques qui vont être encore une
fois problématiques ma question est
simple est-ce que les alors vous avez
répondu en partie
hein est-ce que les solutions les
réponses aujourd'hui du du gouvernement
sont suffisantes vous l'avez dit ça
répond aujourd'hui euh mais je lis he de
vos un des éléments de votre conclusion
générale vous dites clairement que les
difficultés risquent de s'aggraver si
les rénovations réhabilitations ne sont
pas massifié euh et donc qu'est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui euh la massification en
tout cas la volonté de massification est
au rendez-vous et puis euh je vais
terminer par euh une une question euh ou
plutôt oui sur votre point de vue sur
l'impact en fait de la stabilité annoncé
en fait des taux d'intérêt donc est-ce
que aujourd'hui votre postulat est de
dire à partir du moment où les taux
d'intérêt vont être stables euh la
demande sera à nouveau au rendez-vous
une fois que les prix euh baisseront
baisseront est-ce que ça c'est le
postulat que vous défendez et si oui euh
à quel euh à quelle oui à quelle
échéance voilà à quelle échéance je vous
remercie si je peux me permettre par
rapport à ce que vient de dire Amel euh
sur effectivement les mesures qui ont
été prises dans le cadre du dernier PLF
bon le recentrage du PTZ ici au Sénat on
avait dit ce qu'on en pensait euh mais
également la disparition fin 2025 du
Pinel pas pour dire que ce type de
dispositif on sait bien aussi que voilà
il il y avait besoin de de faire en
sorte qu'on soit moins dans une
certaine enfin addicte à ce type de
dispositif mais encore fallait-il
proposer autre chose qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du statut du bailleur privé pour
qu'on puisse enfin euh faire en sorte
que nos concitoyens les particuliers
cont continue à investir dans
l'immobilier dans le logement pour
justement mais à condition qu'ils aient
un retour et un rendement qui soit bien
plus important que ce qu'ils peuvent
aujourd'hui avoir que ce soit en terme
d'investissement locatif propre mais
aussi on le voit par rapport à à la
location touristique par exemple et la
différence qu'il y a entre la location
touristique et la location de longue
durée merci alors je je vais essayer de
pas trop long euh sur sur les les la
comparaison avec la crise de 2008 200009
parce que là on essaie de comparer un
peu les les ordres de grandeur du moment
où on a un retournement de marché ne
serait-ce que pour apprécier si euh je
dirais dans un dans un freinage
euh qui peut se comparer à cette époque
on pense être plutôt au point bas ou
avoir encore une dégradation à venir et
on voit que pour l'instant on est dans
des ampleurs dans des ampleurs assez
comparables à un stade où
euh je dirais les indicateurs notamment
de crédit nous montrent que la
transmission des hausses de taux est ass
enfin des hausses de taux qui ont déjà
eu lieu est assez largement passé dans
les indicateurs de crédit pas encore
dans les indicateurs sur l'économie
réelle
complètement et et donc ça voilà ça nous
donne un point de
comparaison la nature de la crise est un
peu différente puisque la crise de 2008
2009 trouvait quand même son
origine notamment dans le secteur
immobilier alors plutôt aux États-Unis
mais tout de même était précédé d'e
d'une période
probablement insoutenable en terme de
crédit ce qui était pas le cas avant
donc on s'attend aussi pe enfin je
dirais si si on compare sous cet angle
là de l'origine de la crise de 2008-
200009 qui était partiellement pas
intégralement mais partiellement dans
une dynamique de crédit qui était
probablement pas soutenable à moyen
terme on s'attendrait plutôt à ce que la
chute qui suit soit
potentiellement plus importante à
l'époque bon sauf que cette fois-ci on a
aussi plus de hausse des taux donc voilà
pourquoi euh sans que ce soit voilà
d'une
euh d'une d'une précision imparable on
essaie de comparer les deux comme étant
les deux objets les plus les plus
comparables à date euh peut-être pour
pour terminer par votre dernière
question du coup enfin pour pours par V
dernière question
sur qu'attend-on de de la stabilité
annoncée de taux d'intérêt bon
aujourd'hui je dirais les anticipations
que ce soit les anticipations des
analystes ou de marchés vont vers plutôt
des baisses de taux de la BCE qui
commenceraiit sans doute à mi-année euh
dans la mesure où on a globalement déjà
eu la transmission des hausses de taux
passé ça devrait se retrouver euh à
partir du premer semestre dans les taux
au crédit immobiliers qui euh se sont se
sont maintenant
stabilisés autour de 4 % qui pourrait
qui pourrait baisser euh euh donc nous
notre scénario sur les taux longs côté
gouvernement c'est d' une baisse
progressive à partir de de ce début
d'année 2024 et ça ça devrait permettre
un redémarrage de la demande dans la
mesure où ça influe de manière assez
mécanique sur la capacité d'achat des
ménages puisque une une hausse une
baisse de taux de de 200 points de base
sur le crédit à 20 ou 25 ans et très
enfin des effets très important sur sur
la capacité d'achat donc ça devrait ça
devrait permettre un redémarrage du du
marché qui là aussi se fait en décalé
donc qui qu'on attendrait plutôt je
dirais auutournant 24 25 que que dans
l'immédiat mais de manière assez euh
assez progressive
euh sur l'analyse qu'on a fait de de de
la la vacance des logements euh
oui une approche qualitative serait
souhaitable en pratique on n' pas les
données pour le faire voilà pour avoir
les caractéristiques des logements donc
ça reste je dirais une approche un peu
de de de débroussaillage du sujet je
prétends pas du tout qu'on a épuisé le
sujet au contraire euh
mais ça nous semble intéressant et puis
ensuite peut-être au niveau local on
peut avoir cette approche plus plus
qualitative nous avec les données je
dirais France entière on on on on a du
mal à avoir le niveau de granularité qui
qui nous permettrait de de de voir si
oui les caractéristiques sont similair
en terme de taille en terme de nombre de
pièces en terme et
cetera mais en tout cas ça ça c'est
c'est clairement une approche à
développer qui on espère à vocation à se
développer
euh sur le le Pinel et le PTZ alors euh
aurait-il fallu différer dans le temps
je c'est déjà des ajustements été pris
donc par exemple le relèvement des
plafonds de revenu pour le PTZ a été
décidé justement pour euh atténuer les
impacts et notamment sur pour pour
élargir la frangeche de ménage donc avec
dans l'idée à la fois de ne pas
resserrer trop vite euh et en même temps
de resserrer sur à la fois les logements
dont on a besoin et les ménages qui en
ont le plus besoin euh donc il y a déjà
eu des des ajustements en réponse à la
crise que que nous traversons son
notamment
pour pour en atténuer lesffit sur sur
l'impact économique sur le secteur fait
c'est un petit
peu difficile à appréhender et de façon
générale enfin les les perspectives du
secteur du neuf sont difficile à
appréhender pour cette année où à la
fois évidemment on a des signaux sur les
mises en chantier les permis de
construire qui sont qui sont globalement
mauvais
euh et jusqu' enfin on a des perspec
je dirais de de
euh de de stabilisation au moins des
taux qui pourrait permettre un peu plus
de de un redémarrage des des
réservations et puis sur d'autres
indicateurs alors
qu'on qui qui sont pas toujours enfin
qui sont pas toujours désagrégés entre
le neuf et les autres parties mais sur
le secteur du bâtiment en général où en
fait les indicateurs Inc en terme de
d'enquête de conjoncture de carnet de
commande euh sont pas sont pas
particulièrement mauvais par rapport à
leur moyenne de long terme donc on a un
peu de mal honnêtement à à lire ces
signaux et notamment à quel moment on
attendrait un redémarrage sur l'emploi
dans la construction en général l'INC
prévoit des destruction d'emploi
mais je dirais relativement modéré au
regard de la baisse de l'activité de 100
de l'ordre de 15000 emplois sur le
premier semestre dans la construction en
général je vous coupe vous partagez pas
ce qui est dit on perdrait disparition
de 150000 emplois sous 2 ans et et
300000 et sans parler de tous les
emplois qui sont pas direct aujourd'hui
on nous dit bien évidemment mais il va y
avoir des pertes d'emploi chez les
notaires chez les agents immobiliers des
choses comme les déménageurs les
fournisseurs de meubles enfin il y av
voilà il y a toute ce ce ce ce panel de
d'emplois qui sont pas directement dans
dans dans la construction et le bâtiment
mais qui décline de tout cela et donc
les chiffres qui sont annoncés sont
quand même extrêmement important au
regard de ce que vous dites c'est ces
chiffres nous paraissent assez
importants effectivement au regard de ce
qu'on a vu sur donc les derniers
trimestre on a eu des destrictions
d'emploi par exemple au en 2023 mais qui
était aussi de l'ordre de de 15000
emplois dans la
construction on a c'est un secteur qui
en plus est plutôt structurellement en
difficulté de recrutement donc qui aussi
ne ne licencie pas si facilement des
gens qui aura du mal à faire à retrouver
dans dans un an si le secteur repart
mais en tout cas les chiffres nous
paraissent enfin c'est qui qui sont
avancés nous paraissent c'est important
par rapport à à ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui par rapport au climat de
l'emploi dans le secteur euh où
effectivement bon il y a une
partie d'emplois dans la construction
neuve mais il y a aussi tous les emplois
je dirais le gros des emplois dans le
secteur de de la construction c'est des
artisans qui peuvent être bon
électriciens plombiers et cetera qui
interviennent sur du neuf mais pas
seulement qui interviennent aussi sur
des rénovations et euh et et et donc qui
euh l'emploi dans la construction en
général est plutôt plus résilient
que que que ce qu'on peut imaginer mais
en tout voilà ces chiffres n nous nous
paraisse relativement important
peut-être juste un dernier point sur
lequel j'ai pas répondu qui était sur
euh les la rénovation et les
réglementation des passepirs
thermiques je dirais d'abord les les
réponses qui m été faites d'abord pas
complètement sans lien d'ailleurs avec
les questions sur sur le recentrage du
Pinel et du et du PTZ qui permett aussi
de dégager des ressources qui peuvent
être affecté à davantage de soutien à la
rénovation c'est-à-dire du soutien
peut-être plus efficace puisque comme je
disais il y a quand même 1,6 milliard
d'euros supplémentaires pour ma prime
réneuve cette année qui permet aussi de
soutenir ça au-delà de ça l'obstacle à
la maciification me sembla être
davantage du côté de l'offre
c'est-à-dire que la demande de
rénovation est plutôt très forte
aujourd'hui il y a un enjeu de
structuration de l'offre de à la fois en
terme de labellisation des artisans
reconnu RGE de structuration d'offre de
rénovation globale qui permettent aussi
bah de faciliter tout simplement la vie
des particuliers qui veulent qui veulent
rénover leur
logement de aussi contrôle de qualité
des rénovations qui sont effectuées
puisqueil y a aussi une question de
d'asymétrie d'information entre le
propriétaire et puis ensuite de savoir
quel est effectivement le gain
énergétique qui va de la rénovation donc
il y a cet enjeu de fiabilisation du
diagnostic madame Trigano parlait des
des questions sur sur enfin des des des
enjeux autour du DPE de à la fois
fiabilisation d'une diagnostique de
structuration d'une offre de rénovation
globale euh qui permett de répondre à la
demande euh et de contrôle qualité des
travaux en aval qui permettent aussi de
euh de simplement euh euh rassurer et du
coup de déclencher les les rénovations
davantage en amont mais il nous semble
qu'aujourd'hui les obstacles à la
mesification sont plutôt de ce côté euh
de ce côté offre le soutien public a été
assez enfin a été a été
euh euh augmenter à la fois en terme de
montant en terme de davantage cibler les
rénovations d'ampleur d'assurer un reste
à charge qui soit aussi faible que
possible pour les pour les ménages
modestes notamment et également d'une
offre d'accompagnement pour justement
favoriser ces rénovations globales quand
parfois les obstacles sont aussi
informationnels ou de coordonner un
ensemble d'artisans qui interviennent
sur des parties différentes pour avoir
une rénovation efficace et qui crée
aussi des obstacles très très pratiques
et très opérationnels
euh voilà sur le statut du bailleur
privé très honnêtement c'est pas un
sujet sur lequel on a encore vraiment
une analyse très poussée donc je suis
pas forcément en mesure de me prononcer
à ce
stade
question on vous remercie de ces
échanges et puis voilà on en tirera
toute la su scientifique Mo merci
beaucoup et bonne bonne fin de journée à
vous merci beaucoup
merci
tout disruptive et